for the first official response from the
Trump campaign and joining me now
exclusively Mercedes slap Trump's senior
campaign advisor former White House
director of strategic comms Mercedes you
guys worried about anyone tonight be
honest you're trembling no it's it's
quite an entertaining night you have to
admit because what you're starting to
see is this divide amongst Democrats
where you have these governor's saying
wait a second these policies are way too
radical for America we can't force it
down their throats and they're admitting
to it they are admitting some of these
candidates are admitting that the
Democrat Party is going far left and
that's where you're starting to see the
Democrat Party in disarray the Democrat
Party being chaotic where they don't
really know what direction they're going
in so Hickenlooper bullock from montana
there were various points in time maybe
they bashed Trump they have to but
various points in time I listen I'm
going gosh if you only work for the
President on some of these issues you
guys could probably accomplish a lot so
it's it's hard for them and then Tim
Ryan was just totally bollixed up on
trade because he's Ohio and he's like
well I don't want to answer on steel
tariffs because of course it's helped
Ohio they're they're kind of boxed in on
the working-class voter I saw that
repeatedly and that is a problem for the
Democrats it just is yeah there's no
question obviously that they're making a
play for the union voters I mean
obviously you saw Trump go go out and
give this the the beginning pre-debate
speech and at one point I was asking
myself is Trumpkin gonna run for
president next and so they are trying to
make a play the problem has become as a
president Trump where that really has
honed in on helping the American worker
I mean this is why we've seen a boom
when it comes to manufacturing jobs it's
why you've seen wages increase and it's
increased particularly for blue-collar
workers so the president because he has
been strong on trade strong against
China being the bad actor it's benefited
the American worker the Democrats they
don't even have a coherent line of where
they're headed with the American worker
which is I think troubling for them and
their only solution is let's get more
government involved let's make sure you
get free health care and you know you
can get your
wages up that's great one of the other
things they kept saying is this was
toward the end of the debate well we
need to work more with the EU to put
pressure on China I'm thinking what do
they think the Trump administration has
been doing and and in the answer to so
much of what they said tonight is and
certainly tomorrow with Biden is you had
eight years if these ideas are so
obvious and you could have transformed
our economy where was that yeah and I
mean just remember that President Trump
has also made the comment of well Bernie
has been the one against NAFTA and the
one against TPP but remember we still
have u.s. MCA that's stuck in Congress
because Nancy Pelosi hasn't moved it
forward so here you have these Democrats
again you see more chaos more division
they're not agreeing on the policies but
the policies that are the loudest in
that room are the more radical ones it's
Medicare for all that we know is gonna
be tremendously costly we know they're
gonna increase taxes on middle class
they say each of them stumbled in said
bado who just famously and said no no
one's taxes
okay well I'm Warren said that too that
yeah I know it's not gonna be no she
said I she said overall she dodged and I
listened right over all the cost won't
go up okay well Mercedes I also want to
get your reaction to CNN's latest focus
group fiasco how many of you show of
hands are optimistic that a Democrat
will win in 2020
I think that a blind optimism is how we
got Trump we really need a candidate
that is gonna increase Democratic
turnout and not a candidate that's gonna
convince Trump voters to vote for them
because it's not gonna happen
I'm usually optimistic about a lot of
things but I'm really afraid of this
next election
okay well of course we find out that
Detroit's actually doing a little bit
better
Michigan's doing better a lot of it
because of Trump's policies trade
policies and so forth yeah I mean look I
really think that the Democrats are
trying to find their their player the
person they think who could win I mean
that's what they want to focus on yet
their options are those that will just
take America far to the left and so here
you have a president that's been
results-oriented common-sense practical
trying to take the temperature down the
Mercedes right the temperatures got to
come down a little bit I mean the
suburban women you do want them to turn
out I think a lot of it but the
temperature can't stay hot hot hot hot
hot the hypocrisy of the Democrats
saying that they want to secure the
border yet they have done nothing on the
hill to get ice Dyson and Trump could go
into Baltimore with four or five public
sector private sector folks and you know
in a week come up with five policies
that have worked elsewhere yeah and just
say try these let's try these I'll help
you and he's starting with Opportunity
Zones and investment with criminal
justice reform with the fact we got to
move towards school choice and not just
allow for these broken schools we have
policies that we know are gonna work and
here's an art the Democrat leadership
that have been ingrained in these cities
in these urban cities are they willing
to try new ways instead of sticking to
the status I was like you know Shelby
Steele Bob Woodson said on my podcast
today I'd go around Elijah Cummings
Cummings to the people the real
disruptors on the ground who are making
a difference in places like Baltimore
president could work with them make a
huge difference Mercedes great to see
you right in your new role